whoa
whoa no way no
no oh what is going on there citizens of
the reject Nation Greg here joined by
someone I remember when I first met you
it was like that experience when you're
so used to seeing someone on like
television all the time because I'm a
star because you're so freaking famous I
don't know when I met you I was like oh
she's like out of the box that I'm used
to seeing her in and uh he couldn't have
been worse it was just a horrible human
being Roxy striers with us today people
everyone says that that I make the most
intimidating first impression and I'm
just a little softy I think it's because
you're uh you're honest you got like a
edgy crude sense of humor you're welcome
and thank you anyway guys we're gonna
watch some scary ghosts Roxy picked this
one paranormal stuff right shocking
paranormal videos leave Skeptics baffled
I'm the skeptic you're the skeptic I
believe this are you Ted Lazo uh I
believe I don't get the reference I
haven't done that's another bag we don't
have to open today
so I'm not going to apologize for that I
haven't seen last we're about to film a
movie reaction this video is coming to
you guys way after that movie reaction
is up on the channel but I was like no
we should probably shoot a short video
together first Roxy has partnered up
with two other very lovely human beings
dorina and Steph you might have seen on
my brother's Channel a snagged up Roxy
first yeah so no not today javikaway
we're gonna watch this video let's see
where our hearts lie all right for our
souls
oh damnation
how you doing I'm calling and this is
slapped ham today we're looking at some
scary video clips that can't be
explained
get ready like this
when a security guard watching the video
feeds from his post in Mexico reported
for work he probably wasn't expecting to
see any paranormal videos however on
this particular day something appeared
on the closed circuit cameras that he
and his co-workers had a difficult time
explaining
workers standing watch outside he was
shocked to notice a mysterious figure
standing only a few yards away from them
in the footage the figure is completely
dark it appears to be made entirely of
Shadow its shape is clearly human but
compared to the guards we see in the
video it's significantly shorter
is it when the guard watching the camera
they immediately reported to the
co-workers standing nearby
they quickly turned towards the spot to
investigate the two men walked right up
to the figure and shine their
flashlights directly at it however they
can see nothing oh come on it's freaky
the guard watching the video is
perplexed as the shadow still appears on
the monitor what the other two guards
continue searching even appearing to
pass through the shadow figure at some
points whoa but they never see or feel
anything
Peter Pan
throughout the entire investigation The
Apparition never moves
what is this terrifying shadow creature
and why is it only visible on the video
feed the guards who experienced it
firsthand have no explanation come on
that is messed up the demanding counter
to ghost the skirts having a blast
[Laughter]
no you don't think that might be real
the thing is listen Light Shadows
they're literally calling it Shadow
we're putting the light on it and it
goes away shadow
it's humanoid though it's so humanoid
the shape was strange the shape was
strange it's probably like a light pole
or something that mic is so close to
your mouth
I usually have the exact opposite
problems and I'm like yeah I put that
night closer and you're like let's just
shove this mic right this is better
that's much better this is more of your
style it's more is more of my cup of tea
right I think okay let's see what else
is in the store from this video Jesus
Peter Pan yeah well that's what it is
it's a shout out I I get the reference
thank you you can get Ted lasso yeah
well that last was not as famous
Okinawa Air Force Base in Japan thought
they saw something unusual Japanese is
scary we won the video and watch it
again to be sure I'm kind of with you
after a second look they were certain
they had found something that would
stand out among other unexplained
paranormal videos on the internet
the footage which was uploaded to
YouTube by Jose Cruz focuses on an
intersection just outside the base it's
unclear what time it was when the video
was recorded but the sky is Inky black
just behind a road sign in the bottom
left corner of the screen a dark shadow
begins to slowly amass
at first it looks like any ordinary
Shadow as it grows darker it becomes
that's messed up
suddenly one Shadow raises itself from
the ground and flies across the road
oh that was weird actually
a moment before returning to the center
of the street wow as the shadow crosses
the road the street lights allow the
camera to pick up more detail about the
apparition's shape it's like a lost soul
it's rather amorphous the overall shape
appears to be that of a human
how do you know it's lost
I mean it's running in the [ __ ]
circles right now no explanation for the
strange events but it convinced that a
ghost was to blame
it could just be a glitch I'm just gonna
write that off as a question it isn't
unusual for small children to be
fascinated by mirrors babies and
toddlers often find it endlessly amusing
that the child being reflected back at
them copies their movements exactly that
hasn't left for me
him
in one of the internet's more disturbing
paranormal videos however the child in
question may have been correct in
assuming that the image being reflected
back
Theory video was uploaded to Twitter by
nasrala nappi as the child's mother
films him playing with the mirror the
little boy turns towards her together
no way in a shocking twist the
reflection in the mirror doesn't copy
the action is that instead the
reflection Captain is looking forward
and no it's so demonic mirror turning a
terrifying shade of black
that little boy looks like me when I was
little no that has that cannot be weird
that can't be real sickens the
reflection suddenly looks like it's
being fast forwarded as the child in the
mirror rushes to catch up to the
movements of the real life little boy
what the hell is going on something's
wrong with him
the child's father to take him from the
room clearly she wants to keep her child
as far away from the mirror as possible
oh what do you think's going on in this
video don't know that one bogged I'm
bugged come on I don't know what else
that could be but also if that's my kid
I'm putting him in a room and never
floating in the Attic son like come on
that your kid I would freak out yeah or
if it could be a parent pulling a very
elaborate prank how and then being like
we're gonna say this job our child's
possessed for the rest of his life I
don't know you understand the way that
videos work that's not how they work
that'd be kind of crazy if these are
parents just trying to like make a
dollar author kid but who wouldn't right
you know you got to make money you gotta
monetize your children once this is why
I'm not ready to be a parent because
this is the path you would take it's 100
you either make me money or I'm keeping
you in the house or you're costing me
money not nice what I just said is not
nice that's no it's fine it's fine I
assanted you but you're a woman so
you're gonna get more crap
I'm ready for it the smile was weird
like the little smirk not I'm not
talking about the mirror kid I'm talking
about kid kid the actual kid Cape kid
yeah kid kid had a weird smile me or kid
had the weird eyes though that just
seems so digital I feel like they kind
of this would have been creepy enough
without the eyes yeah it's gotta be fake
a hundred percent they made this up it's
a good effect though even if it's fake
it's a good effect I'm kind of afraid to
look in a mirror again what if that's
what's happening when I look away you
wouldn't know you'll get over that
feeling in like five seconds yeah you're
right you're right I love the mirror
yeah look at me that was a good one
though that was a good one like boy
really does look like young me really
yeah not like do them look at me now and
go that's like I I've seen photos of me
when I was is an elaborate prank and it
is you it's off just to finally get you
to believe
when Rosalia Lombardo died of pneumonia
in 1920 at only two years old her father
was heartbroken wanting to preserve her
innocent Beauty for eternity he sought
out Sicilian embalmer and taxidermist
Alfredo salafia nope
his body was well preserved and still
looks remarkably lifelike making her a
popular tourist attraction at the
Capuchin catacombs holy God so many fans
of the Macabre visit the girl's tomb for
a very different reason
in various paranormal videos showing
time-lapse photographs of the mummy's
face tourists who have visited the tomb
point out that her eyelids sometimes
appeared to be closed at other times
they appear to be open giving tourists a
clear view of her perfectly preserved
blue eyes no way they believed that her
spirit still lingers with her Earthly
remains oh man
staff at the Museum have a different
Theory they assert that the mummy's
eyelids are always open the light that
comes into the Tomb at different angles
throughout the day causes an optical
illusion that makes her eyes appear to
be closed at certain times so you hide
the devil spider this logical
explanation paranormal tourists still
flock to the tomb for a chance to see
the allegedly possessed mummy
I kinda want that from me
I think when I die can you do that for
me yeah Greg will make it happen for
I have evidence for oxy settings this
video because that's kind of a cool way
to stay alive forever and haunt
everybody yeah we could do that at the
Santa Monica pier where we'll get it
done for you thanks appreciate you Mikey
no
problema is a popular figure in Latin
American folklore yes according to the
story this legendary woman in white was
abandoned by her husband
the scorned woman attempts to exact
revenge on him by Drowning their three
children after her dastardly act she's
immediately stricken by grief and takes
her own life
in search of her children and any who
hear her mournful cries are said to be
cursed with bad luck
while the legend is popular the weeping
woman doesn't often appear in paranormal
videos yet many believe that La Llorona
is the star of this viral clip uploaded
to YouTube by now you know why
specifically like the video shot in
Mexico City a spot of white gradually
materializes the center of a street
suddenly the spot transforms into a
woman with long dark hair wearing a
white dress it was weird just as she
materializes a car speeding down the
street drives right through her
she never moves even after the car
drives off she remains standing in the
same spot
huh if just seeing the Weeping Woman
brings bad luck this motorist who ran
her over might be in for some serious
trouble
that one was weird it did look like it
could be lighting but also the shape and
like I was dark on top light on bottom
that was weird so the contrast the
colors will make you more of a Believer
yeah also like don't kill your kids
because your husband's a jerk
the pause I just had it I just had to
think for a little bit to make sure I
just I was like well you know it depends
on the situation it I guess it doesn't
depend on every situation more scared
being in this room than I am watching
these videos okay I'm not gonna kill
your kids don't worry yes all zero of
them maybe you already killed them
they don't exist
taking a weird time
cool zigzag all right I'm keeping up
Christmas
this is a soccer game
[Laughter]
actually Greg it's football it's
football probably where since we're
going all over the map here
some football fans leave for their
favorite teams well done well done these
videos to be believed one fan may have
extended their devotion into the
Afterlife as well
County Football Club Stadium in
Nottingham England it appears that a
ghostly figure attempted to get a better
view of the game by staking out a
position on the Stadium's roof right in
a close-up video you can see the faint
figure of a person walking along the
sloped edge of the roof oh come on it's
walking like the goddamn Predator look
at that cloud bro
Cloud's body remains exactly
perpendicular to the roof at all times
even when walking down a steep slope
that is clearly a legs a leg through the
clouds the figure is almost entirely
transparent but its appearance on the
stadium roof has yet to be logically
explained
maybe I'm just smarter than the rest of
you
all in Mexico
to some of the most common ghostly
Legends they often have tragic pack
stories that make their appearances even
more frightening yes in one of the
creepiest paranormal videos shared by
YouTube channel the hidden underbelly
2.0 a mysterious woman in a white dress
gives a couple of security guards a good
reason to be frightened
one of the two security guards working
at Galleria slapas a shopping mall in
Mexico sets out to do his usual Rounds
Around the Mall late one evening I'm
never going to Mexico but it remains
behind to keep an eye on the security
cameras
the guard notices nothing unusual as he
does his rounds he returns to his post
seems concerned the partner asks if he
saw a woman in white in the mall and the
guard replies that he didn't see anyone
when the guard watches the security
video it becomes apparent why his
partner was so frightened
clear as day a woman in a white dress
appears in the footage walking right
past the patrolling guard clear as day
uh
the white dress image is completely
opaque unlike many paranormal videos
showing more transparent ghosts
now that's the guard and that's the I
get it but that was no explanation I
don't think this is clear as day
security video the shopping mall where
she was spotted has been known for
Supernatural occurrences in the past
others have spotted ghostly children in
the morning
it's so ritual sacrifices
you know you Skeptics rich like a
[ __ ]
you're gonna argue technicalities see I
see her clear as night like clear as Fog
she does look like a person but you know
maybe he was just like busy he could
have been texting he didn't see her he
walked right through her next door
and it does kind of look like when
you're really slow it down it tells me
like he's kind of going around her and
she's moving her shoulder he is she's
moving and he was texting stop texting
and walking it's very dangerous what a
terrible security guard then he ought to
be fired for some wandering woman in the
mall who are you calling you Skeptics
I'm sorry to me and my people
[Music]
Jewish people yeah
no my people are more paranoid than
anybody I know
is that racist for me to affirm that no
okay I said it first so you can confirm
yeah offer the Jews are paranoid it's
about mine
yeah I'll control this at it and get
myself in trouble all right I think
there's one more left here let's see if
they can get me home run when Michael
Flannery moved into his wife's family
home he was nervous about the stories
the rest of the family told they were
certain that the house contained some
sort of ghostly presence
people would regularly see and hear
things that they expect but it's
intentionally fake in the family were
terrified of the house even refusing to
go into sir come on I decided to set up
a hidden camera in hopes of solving the
mystery
stockbrot wasn't expecting the video
shot in his bedroom to be so terrific
dude the video clearly depicts what
appears to be a large black cloud flying
quickly into the room and towards the
ceiling behind the camera I don't know
what that is
that is weird
it flies out again a few seconds later
following the same path
oh man some viewers have written off the
video believing that the cloud is simply
a shadow of something passing over a
light bulb however flanderini's family
is certain that the video depicts their
resident Phantom
what is the difference
exactly oh that was your number one come
on slapped him slap him all right maybe
their number one wasn't strong well it
is weird the shadow that goes through
but the shape that they made it like
yeah it's like a kid's dinosaur which
could be their resident
Dino resident I know Barney what are you
doing here that's a movie waiting to be
made resident Dino I love you
I'm a resident I know you can't see oh
it was falling off a cliff somehow
you are gonna let me die I was willing
to I could I could have jump cut it to a
rhyme but I chose to let that play in
real time you trusted me I trusted you I
have faith in the female Jewish race
thanks it's a very specific category
we're a strong group I'm believing in it
now thanks well this is not going to
convert anyone
it's Judaism
to believe it in goats right right and
Judaism unfortunately we don't know we
could that might be the comments I
didn't believe in ghosts but I am going
to become a Jew now yeah yeah well
listen it's a better life if you don't
believe in them because if you really do
start to believe in ghosts you're in
trouble okay good I thought you were
talking about Jews at first then you
clarified with the ghost you need to
really get our dialogue in order here
they are similar all right guys we'll
subscribe to the slap Tam please I'm
gonna follow for a long time also please
follow Roxy on our social media links in
the description box and of course uh the
World Girls Channel watch them go to
Vegas and get drunk and you should do a
video in Mexico that would be amazing
that's where three is from oh is she
from there yeah she's from Mexico oh my
God she's so sweet what made you just
say we should do a video in Mexico the
fact that we just watched three videos
three things that took place in Mexico
right but then all the people were
haunted like why do you want me to go
somewhere oh come on the thumbnail man
of them the clicks will happen if you do
it there all right I'm down all right
catch Roxy in Mexico never coming back
alive
that's how you that's the character then
you're a believer
[Music]